vous regardez rtl
la france a un incroyable talent aurait
bien celle qui a remporté ce concours
sur m6 s'appelle laura lawn elle nous
fait l'amitié de revenir et c'est comme
c'est la saison des hommages et bien
elle veut en rendre à sa manière le
rhône
oui bonjour bonjour à tous bon c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment là on a perdu pas
mal de personnalités on voit après moi
vous savez tous ces chanteurs qui décide
de mourir comme par hasard au moment où
je me lance dans la chanson je pense
c'est un peu facile mais bon voilà
j'avais quand même envie d'en parler
dans une chanson qui s'intitule hommage
ils sont trop forts les journalistes à
chaque fois qu'il ya une star qui meurt
un docu complet sur l'artiste est
diffusée dans les deux heures vu que
l'aîné crosse en fait tu avances
montrant les aux stars en amont avant
qu'elles tirent leur révérence au moins
qu'elle en profite à fond mais moi je
pense aux vedettes raté qui n'auront pas
reportage au toit vieux ringard de la
télé le voici maintenant son hommage
je patrice carmouze tu étais notre ami
nous sommes surpris
east depuis jeudi
[Musique]
oh pas triste
manquera
coucou c'est nous
bye bye c'est toi
te déguiser en jihadistes pour les trois
ans charlie hebdo ton humour toujours
fantaisiste d'aval eu 18 balles dans le
dos des blagues ta vie et ta carrière
nous rappelle cette vérité même quand on
sait vraiment rien faire l'important
c'est de participer
tu es passé tf1 à tmc puis tv5monde cap
tu devais quand même te douter que la
mort serait la prochaine étape un coucou
c'est nous bye bye c'est toi
ciel mon mardi sous terre le jeudi
il ya qu'aznavour qui
veux pas ça c'est étrange lui qui aime
tant le tri
coucou c'est nous bye bye c'est vous
tous ces hommages ça devient relou ça
suffit
tous ces gentils que là
ac on n'en peut plus des best of à la
fnac
[Musique]
arrêtez de clamser on suit pas les
hommages franchement il y en a marre un
par personne ça devient rasoir on
regretterait presque les attentats
[Musique]